[Music]
[Music]
when the shadows unfold when the Sun
hides its gold when the wind and the
cold come come when the path isn't clear
and the stars disappear as men dismay
for at the edge of the sky there's a
moon hanging high when you're lost it'll
try to remind you on a dark night you
come up to the light cuz i shining third
find you
[Music]
till the dawn
turns to dare
in the
right
[Music]
it was clear to us as the script was
developing that this Jazmin was going to
be more powerful than ever
someone who would have this moment of
really standing up and saying I do have
a voice
I will not remain speechless and knowing
that Naomi Scott was gonna take the song
and sing it gave us a lot of confidence
that we could write a song that he's as
big and that is as powerful and that
says as much as it does because she's
the kind of actress and she has the kind
of voice that really can deliver that
God's speechless starts with a solo
piano
[Music]
very intimate and you really get into
this soul of jasmine written in stone
every rule that we would as she gets
taken away by the gods this feeling has
been bubbling up you know and the
amazing alan menken was unset and helped
me figure out how the song fully kicks
in was very special that moment
[Music]
I'll never forget guy coming up with the
idea for a one-shot basically the idea
being that the Camerons spin around
jasmine so it's going to be this whole
continuous thing so we did it in one
take the camera is just following her
[Music]